[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
[Musik]
hallo und herzlich Willkommen Wir haben
einen neuen Fall vorliegen und zwar
buchstäblich vor uns liegen Notizen
Fotos
Zeitungsartikeln und eine Menge Links
auf dem Tablet und es gibt viel zu
erzählen diesmal ich bin Mirko Kasimir
und ich freue mich dass mir Toni Haier
durch diesen Fall hilft hallo zusammen
aber Mirko dieses Story heute die ist
wirklich krass das fängt ja schon mit
dem Namen der Täterin an ich möchte mich
im Voraus entschuldigen wenn ich das
jetzt falsch ausspreche wie ich das
richtig mache könnte mir auch gerne per
Mail schreiben der Link dazu ist in den
Schauen Outs wir sprechen heute nämlich
über goldagi er ist aber Lisa Ranza
sabala Spitzname esti und wirklich ich
bin froh dass er in so kurzen Spitznamen
hat später bekommt sie aber auch noch
einen ganz anderen Spitznamen dann wird
sie nämlich als ICE Lady bekannt und
wenn Namen vielleicht einen Menschen
prägen dann steckt hier hinter einem
sehr einmaligen Namen eine sehr
einmalige komplizierte Persönlichkeit
der Vorname Gold sargi kommt aus dem
baskischen und heißt so viel wie
Morgenlicht es die Balis bedeutet süß
wie Honig denkste die Frau ist dunkel
wie die Rückseite des Mondes und
definitiv giftig wie eine Tarantel ihre
echt unfassbare Geschichte endet damit
dass sie sogar im Gefängnis noch eine
skandalöse Liebesgeschichte anfängt
ebenfalls im Gefängnis verfasst sie mit
einem Co-Autor ihre Autobiografie aber
Mirko lass uns doch mal ganz von vorne
anfangen Gold sargi ist überließ
karanser Zavala wird am 6 september 1978
in Mexiko Stadt geboren ihre Mutter war
der Liebe dorthin aus dem Baskenland in
Spanien gefolgt
der Vater Armando ist ein in Mexiko
bekannter Autor er schreibt über
Esoterik Schamanismus und das Leben der
indianischen Ureinwohner Amerikas so
verständigt die Themen vielleicht
klingen im Privatleben soll vaterkaranza
ein Tyrann gewesen sein noch in istis 5
im lebensjahr zieht die Familie nach
Spanien dort studiert sie später
Wirtschaftswissenschaften an der Uni
Barcelona weil der Vater ist so will
okay das mit dem Vater ist offenbar eine
schwierige Kiste aber wieso oft das ist
da Zündstoff und Probleme gibt das macht
einen ja noch lange nicht so Mörderin
hast du natürlich recht aber es gibt
schon ziemlich früh gefährliche
Bruchstellen in ihrem Leben
in dieser Phase in Spanien verliebt und
verlobt sich es die und darüber sagt sie
später der Mann habe sie als sein
Eigentum gesehen ihr sei harrisch mit
ihr umgesprungen nach ihrem Studium soll
er aber das Interesse an ihr verloren
haben erst die entwickelt daraufhin Mord
Fantasien und plante die Bremsschläuche
seines Autos zu manipulieren boah das
eine Ansage aber aus ihrem Lebenslauf
geht hervor dass sie den Heini bald aus
den Augen verloren haben muss denn nun
ging es nach Deutschland für sie er ist
überlist zieht für kurze Zeit nach
München und arbeitet dort als Au-pair
bei einer befreundeten Familie es zahlt
sich aus dass sie schon als Kind
Deutschunterricht hatte und so bleibt
sie nach dem Job in Bayern und kellnert
in einem Dorf in der Nähe von Nürnberg
in einem Eisladen was jetzt kommt stelle
ich mir in etwa so vor da ist eine junge
ziemlich schöne Frau die in einem
Kuhkaff im einzigen Eiscafe jobbt Tag 1
Tag aus reicht sie Eiswaffeln über den
Tresen kocht Kaffee und richte Eisbecher
an und eines Tages kommt der Mann der
die Kühltruhen für solche eisgeschäfte
verkauft und wartet und
Boom ist die verliebt sich in diesem
kühlgeräteverkäufer und eher in sie der
Mann heißt Holger Holz ist 14 Jahre
älter als sie und stammt aus Berlin er
ist Mitglied bei Harry krischner das ist
eine Sekte die den Hinduismus besonders
streng auslegt und schon wenige Wochen
nach ihrer ersten Begegnung macht er es
dir einen Heiratsantrag jetzt mal ganz
kurz es liegt nicht an Mirko und mir
dass diese Geschichte ein so krasses
Tempo hat das ist alleine
die nächsten Schritte von ihr 2002
heiraten es die und Holger und ziehen
nach Berlin da kellnert sie wieder und
ihr Mann zeigt langsam sein wahres
Gesicht laut ihren späteren Aussagen
nimmt Holz ihr stets das Geld ab dass
sie verdient als sie mit einer Trennung
droht soll er ihr auch ihren Ausweis
abgenommen haben von Psychoterror und
Schlägen ist rückblickend die Rede aber
trotzdem bleibt es die bei dem Mann und
nimmt später erneut eine Arbeit in einem
Eisladen an
und als wäre das ihr ewiges Schicksal
fängt auch dessen Besitzer an sie zu
mobben verweigert ihr zum Beispiel
Toilettenbesuche
SD träumt davon sein Geschäft
abzufackeln aber dazu kommt es nicht
stattdessen nächstes Kapitel in unserem
Fall das Part sieht nach Wien und macht
dort einen eigenen Eisladen auf das
Geschäft befindet sich in der
Oswaldgasse im Bezirk Meidling und heißt
schlägeria der Laden läuft offenbar gut
aber das Privatleben entgleitet den paar
jetzt Holger zwingt es die ebenfalls der
Sekte Harry Krishna beizutreten und
rutscht gleichzeitig in einen Kult um
Waffen und ego-shooterspieler ab es gibt
oft Streit ganz ehrlich mich wunderst du
nicht dass es sie bald die Nase voll hat
und auch nicht dass sie sich neu
verliebt und das ist was jetzt passiert
sie verknallt sich wieder sozusagen im
Dienst nämlich Überraschung in einen
eismaschinenverkäufer
und damit beginnt in dieser rasanten
Geschichte des Kapitel Manfred
Hinterberger so heißt der neue Liebhaber
und wegen ihm lässt sich estibalist von
Holz scheiden lebt aber weiter mit ihm
in der kleinen gemeinsamen Wohnung wir
haben jetzt den 27 April 2008 und
befinden uns in eben dieser kleinen
Wohnung der geschiedenen Eheleute er ist
die Balis karanza ist am Abend von der
Arbeit im Eisladen zurückgekehrt aber
statt Feierabend Entspannung gibt es
Zoff ihr Ex Holger blafft sie den ganzen
Abend schlecht gelaunt an jetzt rechts
sich dass der Waffen nach Holz auch
Schusswaffen im Haus hat
während ihr Ex sich seinem Rechner
zuwendet um ein Ballerspiel zu spielen
holt sie eine baretta und schießt ihm
von hinten dreimal in den Kopf
die Patronen Kaliber 22 dringen zwei Mal
in den Hinterkopf und einmal in die
Schläfer ein das ist die Rekonstruktion
aus ihren Aussagen demnach passierte
alles im Streit und spontan aber es war
wohl nicht nur die miese Stimmung an
diesem Abend die zur Eskalation führte
denn es die wollte schon lange das
Holger aussieht und der weigerte sich
einfach und sie schuldete ihm Geld dass
er in den Laden gesteckt hatte diese
Probleme hat sie nun scheinbar gelöst
aber wohin mit der Leiche hier sind wir
beim makaberen Teil des ersten Mordes er
ist überliss lässt das Opfer tagelang
auf dem Sessel sitzen dann versucht sie
die Leiche zu verbrennen für das aber
wegen starker qualm-entwicklung nicht zu
Ende
schließlich kauft sie im Baumarkt eine
Kettensäge und zerteilt den Körper und
friert die Stücke zunächst ein
nachdem die Wohnung im Herbst desselben
Jahres gekündigt wird landen die
Überreste von Holger Holz einbetoniert
in warnen im Keller unter dem Eisladen
in der ostwaldgasse ah das ist das
grupellos und ich meine was auch für ein
Aufwand und echt erschreckend kalt ist
auch was es die Leuten erzählt die
Holger Holz vermissen der sei nämlich
nach Indien zu einer Sekte gezogen und
deshalb habe sie ihn auch nicht als
vermisst gemeldet
mehrmals schon hat der estibalis
mordfantasien gegenüber verhassten
Männern in ihrem Leben
jetzt ist aus dem grauen im Kopf also
Wirklichkeit geworden die Frau war aber
all die Jahre zuvor schon eine tickende
Zeitbombe und ist es immer noch nach dem
Mord an Holger Holz zieht sie jetzt bei
ihrem Freund Manfred Hinterberger ein
der neue beteiligt sich am Eisladen und
eine Weile scheint alles gut zu gehen
aber Hinterberger geht fremd und als
wäre das nicht schlimm genug zeigt er
jetzt wohl auch herrische Züge und
drängt es überlist zum Beispiel zu
Schönheits-OPs ich finde es ganz ganz
schwer zu fassen sie hat die Eiseskälte
einen Typen zu erschießen und zu
zersägen und lässt sich trotzdem wieder
vom nächsten Mann unterdrücken und sie
hat sich ja mit der Kohle von
Hinterberger auch wieder wirtschaftlich
von einem Kerl abhängig gemacht das tut
mir einerseits Leid und auf der anderen
Seite regt mich einfach furchtbar auf
diesmal bereitet sich es überlist
regelrecht vor sie nimmt Übungsstunden
am Schießstand sie braucht sich Maler
plane um spätere Blutspuren am Tatort zu
vermeiden und sie hat sogar ein Datum
für Ihren nächsten Mord festgelegt wir
haben den 21 November 2010 esti und
Manfred waren zusammen aus zurück in der
Wohnung legt er sich hin sie wartet bis
er schläft und schießt ihm dann viermal
in den Hinterkopf
danach zersiegt Sie Manfred Seelen
ruhigen Teile und friert die Pakete ein
auch diesmal verfrachtet sie nach und
nach alles in den Keller unter dem
Eissalon betoniert sie die Leichenteile
dann in Wannen ein aber die Tat lässt
sich nicht so gut vertuschen wie der
erste Mord die Leute fragen nach Manfred
vier Tage nach den tödlichen Schüssen
meldet es die Wallis Hinterberger bei
der Wiener Polizei als vermisst das
heißt aber nicht dass unsere Frau
skrupellos jetzt die Nerven verliert
ganz im Gegenteil wenig später nämlich
im Dezember 2010 angelt Sie sich den
nächsten Typen ich fasse an dieser
Stelle nochmal zusammen vor zweieinhalb
Jahren hat estibalis ihren Ex-Mann
Holger Holz erschossen und zerstückelt
seine Überreste liegen seitdem im Keller
unter der schleckeria seine Freunde
denken er ist nach Indien ausgewandert
nicht ganz einen Monat später folgt ihm
Manfred Hinterberger mit ihm geht es dir
eine neue Beziehung ein aus dem Wald ein
Kind hervorgehen wird aber jetzt im
Dezember 2010 wird es auch nur noch etwa
sechs Monate dauern bis diese psychisch
höchst auffällige gefährliche Frau
aufliegt unsere Notizen führen uns jetzt
zum Frühsommer 2011 es die führt ihr
Eiscafe weiter und auch ihre Beziehung
mit Roland
sie bekommt aber nicht mit wie sich die
Schlinge zuzieht als in der ostwaldgasse
ein Wasserschaden Auftritt ein Rohr ist
gebrochen zusammen mit Handwerkern
versucht der Betroffene Nachbar den
Schaden in den Kellerräumen des Hauses
zu beheben dabei wird auch der Keller
verschlagt Nummer 6 geöffnet er gehört
zur schlägeria das weiß aber niemand der
Raum hat kein Schild das ihn zuordnet
hier bietet sich den Männern ein
verstörender Anblick eine Pistole drei
Kühltruhen die mit Beton gefüllt wurden
sowie diverse maurertröge und
Blumentöpfe ebenfalls mit Beton gefüllt
die Polizei wird gerufen schon bei einer
ersten Sichtung kommen Leichenteile ans
Tageslicht aber zu wem gehört Verschlag
Nummer 6 tatsächlich fragt an diesem Tag
niemand bei esti nach der nächste Tag
ist der 7 juni 2011 der Wasserrohrbruch
und der polizeiansatz im Keller sind das
Gesprächsthema in der Oswaldgasse
Nachbarn sprechen es dir in ihrem Laden
drauf an und die reagiert blitzschnell
sie lehrt Ihr Konto und ihr
Bankschließfach das Spiel ist aus aber
noch ist unsere doppelmörderin auch frei
im Fuß einer der schrecklichsten
Mordfälle der letzten Jahre hält Polizei
Justiz und die Öffentlichkeit noch lange
in Atem und wie es weitergeht das
erfahrt ihr im nächsten Teil von Tatort
Deutschland wir freuen uns wenn ihr auch
dann wieder mit dabei seid euer Mirko
und eure Toni
Skript und Redaktion Stefan Netzeband
Postproduktion wakeword-studios